[Music]
[Applause]
Beyonce bike gate is pretty much over
because et may have cracked the case so
the person who been Beyonce was now
right because he so who took a bite out
of B at that after-party last December
after jay-z's concert two sources tell
et it was in fact actress Anaya Lathan
who playfully bit the formation singer
one source says quote they don't believe
it was malicious or meant to be mean but
it caught Beyonce completely off-guard
and B didn't like it
when she walked up on her with life its
foot in she started talking to that
actress and some other stuff happened
behind the search for the mystery biters
started after Tiffany Haddish shared a
series of stories about watching an
awkward encounter between an unnamed
actress and queen bee but we have two
notes and I has denied the speculation
surrounding her tweeting on Monday y'all
are funny under no circumstances did I
bite Beyonce and if I did it it would
have been a love bite
[Music]
et has reached out to Sinai's rep for
comment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]